good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Monday happy
post eras Monday I mean happy Monday to
you and you alone let me tell you how
I'm struggling I'm sure you are well of
course with a range of emotions oh I'm
struggling like physically vocally like
I'm not even worried about the
physicality for you like I feel like
emotionally you're struggling the highs
and the lows it all being behind you but
also you haven't had such a good time so
like processing the fun but also it's
bittersweet but also that yes so well
said I couldn't I actually couldn't
never even put it into words as good
um but also because like I plan on like
doing a three hour episode today telling
everyone every minute of every day and
like I feel badly because like you were
supposed to be there like I really don't
want to like rub it in and like you know
I'm not like that you're not you're not
and I'm really I'm so happy for you guys
and all weekend like you guys were
having so much fun and I was just like
there watching through you know
virtually and I was really excited and
happy for you guys when I woke up Sunday
morning and I watched the concert
footage like that was the only moment
where I was like darn darn darn I will
say it did feel like you were there we
did not stop talking about you like the
whole time I love that yeah like it was
just what's Jack's up to how's Jack's
doing how's Harry like Jack Jacks that's
so nice yeah that was like I want you to
tell us everything like we're all living
vicariously through you I'm not jealous
like I it would have been way too much
for me like there is no place for me
they are the whole weekend like
Nashville it's so much yeah no that's
fair so I don't really even feel like
RDH or anything I'm just happy that all
of you guys had the best time we did let
me tell you how the Vlog is up so if you
want like hardcore footage from the
whole weekend of course we've got great
concert footage in there behind the
scenes of The Suite you know the drama
with the bus did you hear about the
drama with the Bible I didn't I watched
the Vlog this morning drama with the bus
there was lots of you know lots of
happening so it's all in the Vlog it's
on patreon already I edited it on the
plane I knew if I didn't edit it I'd so
many videos I knew if I didn't edit it
on the plane I would have waited like
two weeks yeah so it's up it's there
enjoy but I will tell you guys
everything that you need to know about
the concert I'll start at the beginning
but let me just say like if you've been
thinking like should I go to this
concert like it's a lot of money it's
it's a lot of money like especially
since we traveled it was just like added
expenses
um
I do not regret one cent spent except
maybe you know on the bus because there
was drama with the bus but whatever it
was so next level it was such a
Sensational I don't think there aren't
even words for like the production value
for the experience like and I was a
little panicked because like I really
wanted you know to be as close as
possible and we were high up like our
suite was above the 200 level and I
wouldn't have had it any other way
there's so many elements there were so
many things that she put in so much
thought put into like the production of
the show that you really can only see at
a glance like if you can see the whole
thing pyrotechnics the stage is a screen
so like it is changing like there was
and there were screens everywhere so you
could see up close like she really made
sure no matter where you are in the
stadium like you can see everything we
saw everything the seats were amazing
oh my God I was exhausted after the
first era and I'm like this [__] has to
go for two and a half more hours her
professionalism and her stamina and her
Talent were just on display it was
unlike anything I've been to a lot of
concerts and all of them are amazing
there's nothing like seeing Taylor live
and this is Far and Away her most
impressive showing yet like she's such a
star it was it was emotional it was
cathartic it was exciting and [__] I
have seen every [__] thing I know the
concert front front and back and I was
like this is next I was so annoying yeah
but people seem to enjoy it in the sweet
um and I was still on my toes like you
know because she throws things in what
is she gonna say next like it doesn't
even matter having seen the whole
production on Tick Tock months in
advance it's still so exciting and I can
imagine how really exciting it is if you
like have no idea what's coming you know
yeah so we got to Nashville on Thursday
um the city was a blaze I was talking on
the podcast on Friday about how it was
just on fire like everything was backed
up like you order a new breeds like it's
three times the way like everything down
to like oh you gotta go pee at Starbucks
the city was just packed
Friday we were supposed to go out on the
boat but it was the whole weekend called
for rain
and that's an important fact I'll come
back to later in the story so we
canceled our boat even though it ended
up being beautiful the the boat company
was like everyone's canceling you want
to cancel them you're like okay we
didn't even need to cancel it was
gorgeous like everyone else but it
actually was a little chilly I was like
actually happy we were on a boat you
know and that's a lot like I actually
think you guys maybe were overestimating
your energy energy levels like you had
the Spritz event that night concert like
you can't kick off the weekend with a
boat no we took it easy Friday during
the day we all just like hung out we all
hadn't seen each other so we all just
like congregated at the Airbnb where a
lot of people were staying it had like
this great patio and you know Shannon
got to meet Lauren you know TNN meeting
TNN uh the December entrance it was a
the redheads were there the snatchler
formerly
known as best of both probably a podcast
now a full-time redhead Ben
it was a TN [__] I should have like
branded it as a TNN if I had like even
the smallest business Acumen like I
would have thought of that and like live
in you like left gift bags in
everybody's beds you know like a TNN
trip [__] damn how did we totally miss
that because that's because our friends
are our family and our family is our
business like that's just who we are
yeah
the damn [__] this opportunity could
have expensed the whole thing literally
um so we all just like hung out on
Friday it was nice we just like sat
outside ordered so much food Hattie B's
you know local delicacy and just listen
to music and chilled and then Friday
night was a big it was just a weird
weird coincidence we didn't even time it
that the weekend we were going to
Nashville for era's tour was also going
to be the weekend that Spritz was going
to be available in Market in Nashville
but it all just happened so
coincidentally that we decided to throw
this big event at the Thompson Hotel
rooftop which is a bar that now carries
Spritz society and it was like Shannon's
big coming out party so I like the
Nashville influencers were there all the
toasters were there it was so much fun
like I guess like a party that's like
about you is always fun but it was more
fun than I expected it looks really fun
it really was and also it's just like a
gorgeous rooftop you know it was a
premium event space there was charcucci
there was food there was drinks there
was Spritz it was so fun and we used it
as like a little pregame for the night
everyone was just having such a blast
and really every
business in Nashville was exclusively
playing Taylor and I thought maybe I was
like oh how nice I walked in like
they're playing Taylor for me but then
it was like there wasn't one other
artist being played it was just like it
was deep Cuts Like Wonderland the last
great American Dynasty like really deep
and everyone it was just like the city
had this like electricity it was really
unlike anything I'll probably ever
experience in my life like everyone was
just there for a common purpose and the
Spritz event was so fun and I looked so
gorgeous it was just isn't it great when
that works out for you like your outfit
works and I didn't even I wasn't I it
wasn't even like a fancy event but I
went shopping for the era's tour no you
Rose to the occasion and also you're a
business owner you're not just like you
know someone else going to an attendant
who's going there to pregame and drink
spray it's like you have to have your
business cap on I had my businesswoman
outfit on and it was like spritzy it was
on brand it was I just felt great and
when you feel great you feel great you
know you feel great you look great sorry
I may look great you feel great that's
no when you look great you feel great
when you feel great you don't always
look great you know you wouldn't know
right so it was just it was it was a
great way to kick off the night and then
we went to Topgolf and you could catch
me on every corner of that Topgolf
facility saying it's golf it's not golf
it's Topgolf and it really was myself
I'm so glad you brought that up it's not
in the Vlog it's on the Vlog because
like I was being Monica Geller like
let's put our names in and let's all go
for our turn and Margo and Ben were like
let me go for Abe's turn and I was like
come on like nobody weren't
respecting the Integrity of Topgolf no
it was so annoying and like At first
like people were just playing randomly
and then I was like wait let's all put
our names in and like go for real and
like you know when you go bowling you
like put in like dumb names yeah I put
in everyone's silly names you know and
no one was respecting the names I'm
surprised at Ben that he wouldn't want
to like you know go over under 90. we
have to watch that every weekend but now
here's a real golf competition and you
don't want to participate no he did but
like he didn't like that he would get to
go two times then have to wait for six
other people to go he said Margo I'll go
free when Margo was like drinking and
like eating and socializing she was like
yeah Ben go and I'm like no understood
it's unfair So eventually I gave up I
was like being like such a teacher but
not in a negative way I love teachers
like teachers enforce rules yeah yeah I
was being such like a rule following
like brown noser honestly like I felt
myself being toxic and annoying that
eventually I gave up but like it was
disheartening it's really frustrating
yeah but like then like no one was
failing My Vibe and then I was being
like the annoying person at Topgolf so I
eventually let it go so there wasn't a
winner I mean if there was gonna be a
winner it was going to be Ben it was
like it was unfair yeah and you know
what we had two bays we should have
split it up girls and boys 100 but Ben
wanted to like stunt on the girls he was
the only boy
well actually Abe and Ryan were with us
too but they don't play golf so like it
doesn't matter Ben was like the only
like golfer who wanted to play with the
girls yeah yeah he was being so toxic
because he wanted to crush you literally
literally and he did so it's like oh how
fun it got I was like great this is so
fun Ben thanks but it was also just like
a great place to decompress from the
Spritz event load up we ate so much ben
ate too much Ben had to go home
afterwards like I'm spoiling the Box
um but it was it was actually so much
fun and there were like so many toasters
there and there was like actually
everyone was freaking out I don't know
who it was but like this big Draft pick
from the NFL was like right next to us
and everyone was like did Ben know who
because I actually watched a lot of the
draft I might even know who uh I I don't
know if Ben knew but I'm sure he did
like everyone knew and we were like
throwing Margo and Emily we're like go
go and they were like no I'm like come
on girls oh my God to be young youth is
wasted on the young literally
um so it was just fabulous and also it
was just like a hot spot you know it was
packed and it was a great beverage drink
situation before we all needed to like
reload recharge after Spritz before The
Honky Tonks then we went oh and when we
left Topgolf I don't really understand
like the geography of Nashville but we
must have been close to the stadium
because when we walked out we heard the
one oh my God and everyone's like that's
the stadium I'm like no it's someone's
Uber like this Uber had just pulled up
I'm like you guys I was being so like
negative I'm like it's not and then we
heard like crazy Applause I was like oh
my God it's the stadium it was actually
so cool and it just made it like even
more exciting for the next night we're
like we're getting bits and pieces bits
and pieces
so then we went honky talking
always a blast like and it was
Friday day was Pete who was our friend
Kristen's husband his birthday so at
Topgolf we celebrated and then at
midnight at The Honky Tonks we kind of
transferred you know a transition of
power to the snatchler's birthday yes we
like took shots at midnight The Honky
Tonk band it was like there was kind of
drama there's always drama so let me
tell you those Honky Tonk cover bands
like they're on a power trip like
they're rightfully so yeah like they are
this they are the Taylor Swift of that
establishment right and they did not
like the comparison because everyone at
the bar was girls in sparkly hats like
sure play Dierks Bentley play whatever
but like Play Taylor come on like some
of us weren't able to get tickets some
of us are going tomorrow like we're here
for Taylor like give us something yeah
my God after every song they played and
we were being good audience members we
were like yeah we loved the song and
then everyone would start to chant
Taylor Taylor these guys did not like
that like they were very like toxic
masculinity like they were like you want
to see Taylor go buy money we're not
making money on Taylor I'm like oh my
God calm down like chilling she has some
country deep Cuts Like You could play it
like you could do your own thing with it
no at the end of the day like
when you're uh a honky tonk cover band
like so much of your money is made from
tips and song requests you have to pay
for song requests so like it would only
behoove you to give the crowd what they
want but like I literally paid 20 twice
for two different songs and they didn't
play it and I was like wait like what
about he's like somebody just gave me 45
like it was really like an auction it
was so toxic in there like it was just
like I was like okay the thing is it
always is even outside of Taylor like
yeah if you request certain country
songs like either they're too Niche and
not everyone knows the words and they
won't play it or it's like too corny
they're just like kind of on a power
trip that they're the real country
artists and like all these tourists are
faking but like yeah we're [__]
tourists yeah they came from National
experience play Life is a Highway
literally not Alan Jackson
Alan Jackson's Lander check it you don't
respect Alan Jackson I don't know her
that's such a niche toast story I don't
even remember it can you tell me like we
were honky talking with toasters like
many years ago many years ago what after
like we did something in actual one of
your shows where we did a toast live
show we were having the best time you
know we just keep requesting the same
three songs right and Luke Combs Rascal
Flatts and like Shania Twain yeah and
then the band played like an Alan
Jackson song and Claudia and I were like
visibly pissed and just went to do like
something else he was over it and we
weren't hiding it and one of the
toasters came up to you and was like you
don't respect Alan Jackson she was dead
[__] serious dead serious I was like
no do you like I was like why am I in
trouble I was like
no I I literally honestly at that moment
I hadn't heard of Alan Jackson
you know I'm like like I know until they
make a biopic about him I don't know him
so true and like I respect country music
but like I draw the line at Alan Jackson
you know it's like listen just leave us
alone we're just trying to have fun you
know we're just trying to have fun yeah
like just stop yeah I'm like I don't
need to be yelled at like I'm drunk you
know yeah so they were like then they
finally played love story and it
happened to be at midnight when the
clock strike 12 for Margo somebody
brought us around of shots like it was
really a Hallelujah Night like it was
perfect I think snatcher had like the
best birthday it was so fun and then I
exerted like so much energy at love
story like I needed to take a break so I
went outside with my friend Abe and
once you leave the bar the Bars were so
crazy the lines like once you leave like
it's not like you can just come back in
so we got kicked out I was like oh I
guess we'll go home like it was yeah it
was for the best I honestly needed to go
home and some of the people in our group
stayed out till three and like if I
stayed out till three I know my limits
like I would not have been okay you
needed to be for Taylor yeah for Taylor
everything happens the way that it was
meant to happen but it was like honky
Tonkin I've never had a bad time honky
tonking and I know those bars on
Broadway are considered like touristy I
think there is no greater place like I
will never turn down a night out at on
Broadway so much I mean the lines it was
crazy and we left at 12 30 and we walked
from Broadway back to our hotel 10
minute walk and that was an hour and a
half after the Taylor concert had ended
and it was a mass Exodus still because
like the pedestrian bridge that
basically takes you from the stadium you
cross the bridge back into like downtown
Nashville where the bars are
herds of people an hour and a half later
like I couldn't believe how I thought
maybe we like escaped the post concert
drama because it was an hour and a half
after the concert it ended oh my God I
was like it was it was pandemonium like
me and Abe were like literally like if
we didn't hold hands like we would have
gotten lost in the mix it was crazy
Ben missed the whole night because he
ate too much at Topgolf and you'll hear
why in the Vlog then Saturday day
I'm gonna tell you about but it's
brought to you by and wait a new sponsor
I'm so excited about you guys
Chamberlain coffee is a new sponsor of
the toast so introducing Chamberlain
coffee's new ready to drink collection
inspired by Emma Chamberlain's uh daily
cold brew recipe so Chamberlain coffee
just launched four pimp plant-based
latte flavors in a can that are
available exclusively at Walmart you
shake them well serve them cold for the
best coffee experience I saw um like
weeks ago everybody like gagging that
these were available at Walmart on Tick
Tock and we have them at the studio now
and you know what because I'm like you
know transitioning into like my coffee
era they're delicious and something
about it being in a can just like so
easily readily available when you were
out we had all of our guests come and I
was like can I get you anything like
coffee everyone drank the Chamberlain
coffee they loved it poured it over ice
some drink it straight from the can it
was really my favorite story of yours
which I'll tell after this ad breaks and
it's Chamberlain coffee would have
solved all your problems now you can
take your now you can take your favorite
cold brew latte on the go anytime
anywhere you'll have coffee on hand to
grab in seconds anytime and there's no
prep required so if like you every like
me Everything You Touch in the kitchen
turns to like crap just save yourself
the trouble you don't need a bunch of
ingredients just get the cans leave them
in your fridge it's good when you have
company over it's good in the morning
grab it on the go you know where girls
on the go we're girlies with businesses
we're taking trips we're doing things
Chamberlain coffee for a limited time
our listeners can get a free Chamberlain
coffee latte when they purchase the can
terms and conditions apply visit
chamberlaincoffee.com the toast for the
offer details again that's
chamberlaincoffee.com the toast for
offer details terms and conditions apply
um yeah tell that story It's the
funniest thing so when Claudia moved
into her first big girl apartment she
was so excited about all her big girl
tanks and she was having people over
because she was doing like a photo shoot
at her house oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
and you know Claudia wanting to be like
the house that is always stocked and has
the Chargers and has like everything you
need so she's like fills up on Diet Coke
water Seltzer anything so she has all
these people in her house and she's like
so excited to be hostess with Moses like
can I get you anything a coffee I mean
water Seltzer soda and they're like yeah
I'll take a a coffee and I at that point
I only recently started drinking coffee
like it never even crossed my mind that
like a thing people drink in other
people's homes is like a coffee I didn't
have like a Keurig or nothing I was like
a coffee I was like an alien from
another planet how do you make a coffee
I said you guys want anything like I
have everything like let me get you a
Seltzer like a sparkling yeah I'll take
a coffee coffee it was like a moment I
will never forget because I felt so dumb
it's just weren't as groan as he thought
I wasn't as grown as I thought I was and
honestly like I just was really thinking
of myself like when I go to people's
home I'll take a Diet Coke a Snapple a
Seltzer a water Pellegrino I've never
once asked for a coffee and but it's a
very normal thing to ask duh and if you
don't drink coffee like you don't need a
big ass carrig in your house but a
couple Chamberlain coffees would have
cured it all
um okay so Saturday day of concert we
knew we needed to take it easy but there
was a Knicks game so Ben obviously like
had to make us all go you know watch it
and we were gonna go to a bar but then
we were like you know let's just go back
to the Airbnb and watch it they had this
great outdoor area so we really just
took it easy I mean the concert
she goes on at eight
Phoebe Bridgers went on at seven I think
there was another opener at six
with all the traffic and everything like
we all decided to be ready by five
o'clock and like have some drinks and
leave at six like we didn't I mean we
all met up at my hotels and it was only
a mile from who was the other opener I
don't know was it it wasn't a b c d e f
e oh yes it was we saw her sorry Gail oh
I didn't know you saw her I thought I
was just playing on the speakers do you
have fomo from that your favorite girl
oh it's not 10 Things I Hate About You
Dana's husband Josh loved that song he
was like so happy we made it in time he
was like hey it was so funny how all the
husbands had like different they all
really like knew and loved Taylor but
Kristen's husband Pete who was like the
MVP of the weekend I didn't realize how
big of a Swifty he was it's the biggest
Phoebe Bridgers fan we were like taking
videos of him he looked so sweet and
innocent like everyone we weren't like a
big Phoebe Bridger script we all sat and
like watched him respected he was like
standing up and like swaying and he knew
all the words it was the cutest thing
like it was so cute so I was really glad
he got that moment
um but so we didn't really do anything
because we all like we took our time
getting ready and we were like making
tick tocks and stuff so we literally
woke up like ate watched them in the
next game but pretty much spent the
whole day getting ready for the concert
and all my outfit trial and tribulations
is in the Vlog because there was a
journey and I was alone with Ben who's
always like you look great and I'm like
really he's like actually no like
someone helpful so we
met up at my hotel Shannon and her
friend Kyle did come with us although
they weren't in our suite but like
honestly to get to the stadium is such
chaos like we all needed to go together
and it was pretty seamless honestly um
we had a parking pass there was traffic
but we had accounted time-wise by the
time we get there got there Gail was in
the middle of her set so it was good we
had food and drinks in the suite
honestly like it was a huge luxury to be
in the suite and because we were so many
people the cost of the suite and the
cost like per person wasn't like that
much more than what I'm sure everyone
else paid the tickets were really
expensive but the fact that we like
didn't have to go wait in lines for food
and that was like the biggest privilege
it was so luxurious honestly and of
course I did the menu because I'm like
you know the director of this trip and I
think I did a good job even though like
there was I heard some people talking
some [__] about my hummus wraps like
that that wasn't cool it's but you need
to have a vegetarian option right
because Abe Margot Ben don't eat me I'm
sure there's other people in the group
who don't need me so I did chicken
fingers for like everyone a Caesar salad
for the health conscious crew and
grilled vegetable hummus wraps not good
no it's like that's the vegetarian
option but it's never good it's never
been good I've never had a good one and
like I ate before so like I I was really
more focused on the the liquor and I
didn't want to order like so much food
like the [__] it was so pricey like I
was just trying to like get us bare
minimum so nobody like fainted from you
know exertion
so and mac and cheese I did a good job
yeah yeah
um
so we all like just chilled and drank
until the concerts like the energy like
we all were just like freaking like it
was
it was just it was so exciting and there
was you know about an hour that we all
just like were waiting and it was so
exciting and we weren't even like we
weren't even like annoyed we were just
like 59 minutes 58 minutes and then the
show started
from the minute that [__] got on stage
to the minute she left like she did not
stop what did she opened with
it's been a long time coming but it's
you and me that's my whole a very short
Miss Americana and then straight into
death by a Thousand Cuts which was
really just what was your favorite era
to watch
oh my God that's such a good question I
will say like I was really in my
feelings and like feeling just like out
of this world during lover because it
was the first one yeah and Lover's like
underrated I agree the songs themselves
are underrated I think they were like
kind of eclipsed by the era the
phoniness of the era but the songs are
sorry wow it was just like I think you
mean the aesthetic yeah the the
aesthetic was like very phony especially
after a reputation like she went from so
dark like it was just like
a very manufactured well I think it was
eclipsed by like the singles me you need
to calm down it was like those songs are
really yeah not my favorite like heart
like touching your heart yeah you know
yeah yeah that's not it's not what
Taylor can do best and then you forget
about the Archer yes oh my God that was
a single the Archer like really got to
me I don't even that's not even like one
of my favorite songs I was so moved by
it once her voice sounded so good the
visuals were just like these pastel
clouds it was all very ethereal and I
just was like it was that was the song
where I was like wow like I'm seeing
this [__] like I've been thinking about
this for so long and and it was just it
was overwhelming and it was very
emotional and like the Archer really got
to me and I wouldn't have expected that
you know yeah
and so in terms of my favorite I'm such
an Ever more girly like folklore I I
have to probably say those but there
wasn't a bad era in the place even I
thought like by the time midnights came
around I was like I'll probably be tired
and midnight is really not one of my
like top five albums I was like you know
what maybe I'll be like sit I couldn't
get enough I have a whole new respect
for midnight obsessed with midnight
Mastermind like I was like I was not
okay if anything the concert gave me an
appreciation for eras I might have
looked past in the past you know yeah
like lover like like midnights because
like I'm like you know me I'm such a
reputation
reputation always good it's such a good
vibe and you know me like I hate look
what you made me do like I think it's
the worst song ever after 10 years it's
grown on me Jackie I was popping my
[__] so far
I agree the whole album was remember
when we first listened to it it came out
at midnight we were in the Bahamas and
we were like the [__] we were so
confused it was exactly perfectly put so
ahead of its time reputation was amazing
and the graphics and that's why I was
like so happy we were up because there
was like this light show that you
couldn't see if you were on the floor
there was fire there was fireworks like
it was such a production like it was
reputation was sickening and tell us
about the moon during all too well I saw
that Moon from my window so in terms of
the rain let me go back to that it was
supposed to rain Friday night and people
were freaking out and it didn't but it
drizzled a little bit during fearless
and everyone was like oh this is Kismet
and beautiful like no problem
we couldn't have had a more gorgeous day
except it was like a little cloudy but
who cares like that means it wasn't
sunny
a little cutie so the moon wasn't out
and I wouldn't even notice if the moon
was out like I'm not like I was looking
at the moon yeah but during all too well
10 minute version literally we were
watching I don't know who pointed it out
these clouds started to part
and out came I didn't even realize it
was a full moon the most gorgeous yellow
full moon during all too well 10 minute
version just like literally shining a
light on the stadium it was giving like
Godly Vibes like it was it was crazy
like we were all we couldn't we couldn't
get over it we were talking about the
moon the whole time
it was magical magical
magical how is all too about 10 minutes
I think that was the part in when I was
watching your guys's stories where I was
like darn darn darn yeah I mean
it was
oh I mean there was drama she was like
about to start singing it or no where
was the drama yeah she was like she was
about to start singing it and her
in-ears went out so she's like hey guys
I can't hear my in-ears and then she was
like just like Dilly dallying and then
they came back and then she did the
Phoebe Bridgers performance Phoebe
Bridgers came out to sing nothing new
which was so good and before they
started that her ears went on again and
they didn't come back so literally two
like Tech guys came out her thing had
gotten unpacked uh her pack and on her
back and gotten unplugged so they
plugged it back in but she was like
explaining she's like you guys I cannot
perform with these like if you only
Could Hear What I Hear without these
things in like I hear every voice in
this Stadium echoed over and over and
over so was like a lesson in Tech you
know me a tech girl I I loved it I loved
it and then so there was a lot of drama
but all too well 10 minute version you
you would think like wow she spends 10
minutes on one song not long enough it
might as well have been 30 seconds like
it was
her vocals are so good and I will say
like throughout her career she's
definitely
focused on getting her vocals to like
the best place she did not miss a single
note a high note really her register
goes so low me and Abraham we were like
um like a water when you should bro her
register goes so low but also so high
it's so impressive or what I remember it
all yeah
champagne problems like I was like okay
man and like it was giving like low
register her vocals were on point her
dancing is so good like every there was
I can't even I can't criticize one thing
and you know me I'm a like a
professional critic even for things that
I love like I could criticize I would
have said it was too long you know I got
tired it wasn't long enough when I got
back on the bus I was like energized I
cannot complain about one thing the
weather was perfect the energy like
everyone in the stadium like you saw
friends you saw mothers and daughters
like son fathers and daughters like it
was so sweet there wasn't one miserable
person in the whole thing except for
that girl that made that sorry talk
there was one miserable person somebody
made a tick tock that went viral talking
about how she got seated yes 300 000
views talking about how it got she got
seated next to the most annoying fake
ass Swifty fake influencer who didn't
stop filming the whole time and the
person she was talking about was Shannon
Shannon who is the biggest Swifty uh
she's not a fake ass influencer she's
extremely legitimate she's a podcast on
TNN
um and what's wrong did you see him ever
literally everyone films the whole time
what we should all spend all of our
money not to remember this like so rude
and the girls video blew up and the
comments were so here for Shannon
everyone being like you're giving mean
girl energy Taylor has literally said
like there's nothing worse than people
who like make fun of someone else for
being excited about something that's
like so a not Taylor thing yeah and
every first of all like have you seen
the Eris tour channel on Tick Tock
everyone films everything like that's
okay I thought we were past like making
fun of people for filming like it was so
loser energy and I'm so glad the
comments like were on Shannon's side and
Shannon left the best comment like there
couldn't have been a better rebuttal she
literally responded I had a marvelous
time run everything like best comment
ever and the girl like it's just like
you literally spent all this money for
you and I think she was with her
daughter to be on floor seats and you're
gonna spend the whole time thinking
about the girl next to you
look watch the videos that you posted
Shannon's having the time of her life
and you're [__] Drake comfortable
miserable face like please miserable way
so besides for her everyone in the
stadium was just like understanding how
this was like the night of our lives
like we were all collectively gonna have
a Hallelujah night everyone was passing
around friendship bracelets I got
friendship bracelets
so what's that about at the show you
know I didn't know there was a thing I
was like I guess people are just oh it's
about make the friendship bracelets take
the moment and taste it you've got to
see someone dress up as a friendship I'm
sure that they did you see any good
outfits of people dressed up like in
something memorable not memorable I
wasn't really looking but everyone just
looked like they were in their Sunday
Best so you know like sparkles everyone
did Glam like everyone looked nice and
it was nice that is nice so what do your
bracelets say um one of them says Dirty
Lou
I was in a Suites like I couldn't get
them but Shannon got back on the bus she
said Claudia I have a thousand bracelets
for you um one of them says toasters
version oh I love that you wanted
chicken
thank you and then the other one says
see the good which obviously wasn't
meant for me no because I see the bat no
no that's not I wouldn't say that's your
brand it was just
were there any other songs that hit you
differently than you expected that like
were Peak moments for you like the
Archer Marjorie and by the way I was
excited Marjorie is one of my favorites
from Evermore but it was never a song
like I really related to
um and that's just because I wasn't
listening to it in the right way that's
what Abe and I were saying because Abe
got really choked up during lover and
he's like I never thought about that
song Through the perspective of
friendship like and he was just there
with like people who love him like it
was really sweet and for me Marjorie I
know it's about her grandma but like if
you listen to it it's actually a song
just like about grief and I got really
choked up and it was just it was so
beautiful champagne problems there were
like songs I've been waiting to hear
live my whole life and I got to hear
them you know like
Fearless yeah I had never heard Fearless
live because my first Halo show was
1989. yeah and she only did the songs
from 1989. she did a bunch of songs from
other albums in reputation but she
didn't sing Fearless
um and like for me like I was going
through the experience of like listening
to all these songs and then thinking
back like what point in my life I used
to listen to these songs like when we
don't live together we used to listen to
Fearless like yeah it was like emotional
in that way because I was thinking about
like all the times in my life and like
not me like gonna cry again like just
thinking about all the times in my life
where like I had heard those songs and
it was just like putting into
perspective because she was saying like
these are songs from the last 17 years
of my career and I'm like damn I've been
there for most of it so it was just it
was uh it was like an outer body
experience it really was it was it was
amazing and I honestly I cannot
recommend going I think like of course
everyone wants to go but people are like
I don't know it's a lot of work and it's
a lot of travel like if you can do it I
think it'll be a night like I will be
remembering for the rest of my life like
it was so magical and then the surprise
songs
I don't want to spoil the Vlog was that
not the best part of the Vlog I you know
what I had watched um I just wanted to
oh my God not you skipping through my
voice I skipped through a little bit of
the concert because I'd watch it on
stories and I wanted to like give you my
okay that it was good to go okay well
you should watch it because there was
like there was kind of like a
misunderstanding between like me and
Taylor I
um I'll just just watch it in the Vlog I
thought we were getting a song on my
list when she played out of the woods
because she's giving hints and I was
like pretty sure I figured it out and
ended up being out of the woods which is
for me like I don't think I could have
gotten a better song like it wasn't even
on my list but it doesn't like that is
my favorite [__] song like so happy
and then we got 15 and Abigail was there
and we should have known we should have
known yeah yeah yeah and it was so
that's another song like we used to
listen like at camp like and Kristen was
Aaron Kristen is our friend from camp
and it was just like it was too much
like it was so it was honestly I have no
complaints about my secret songs like of
course I wanted peace but like who cares
like I got two such good songs I can't
even complain and you know I could
complain about anything
um and they were actually celebs there
Reese Witherspoon was at our show
Mariska Hargitay was at our show Gigi
Matt Healy story okay stories so we get
in the stories Matthew Lee oh okay it's
part of the stories okay because we sat
down for Phoebe Bridgers and Margo was
like editing her photos and I was like
Margo I think that's Matt Healey playing
the guitar she's like no it's not I'm
like it's not sure like I'm telling you
it is she like dismissed me for five
minutes until they put it back on screen
I'm like that's her look look and it was
him and I know they're friends and like
maybe that's not weird but there's a lot
at play there's a lot at play and we'll
get to all of it in the stories so
that's your full National eras recap
best night of my [__] life if you
want like the boots on the ground behind
the scenes look everyone's outfits
everyone's
favorite Parts head over to patreon.com
toast the Vlog is up it's one of turdy's
best directorial efforts I would say
thank you also I just want to like clue
you in
um Becky if everyone starts calling her
Rita now I just have to tell you that
there was um a redhead who we were all
sitting in the lobby of the hotel and
she goes to Dana are you Dana from the
toast
and she was like yeah and she was like
oh my God Rita she confused RIT with
Rita but honestly it's her new name now
and we're all obsessed she is a reader
no honestly I can't believe we never
called to Rita before like it it was so
seamless like it's Rita you know like
that's like when turny Lou came out
right like some nicknames just stick and
she's Rita now so if you feel confused
as to why we're now calling Becky from
the redheads Rita that's why it's like
altivia
and of course Satchel Satchel the
satchelor and happy birthday satchel and
then we got to celebrate last night
together you guys came home oh yes we
had a nice night together happy birthday
Satchel happy birthday Pete literally
everyone is born this week it was
Shapiro's birthday it was wine Red's
birthday and today's my friend Alicia's
birthday happy birthday at least you
have to text you happy birthday Alicia
like it's just Birthday everyone I know
I don't know if it's just like a me
thing or if it's like a universal thing
maybe you would just attract Tauruses
everyone I know I hate can't believe I
said that yeah that was like so losery
of you no I think there's people who
like are like yeah she attracts Tauruses
yeah but you're not one of those people
no I know but I was just speaking for
them okay we do represent everyone and
I'm just trying to all offer an
alternative perspective yeah
like we don't really attract a lot of
Leo's actually like markovicious Leo
Danny Handler's Leo okay we don't
attract a lot of Pisces uh see I don't
know which one Pisces is but you would
know if you knew yeah no you're tax tax
okay should we get into the story even
though we had no choice that was the
main story we have no choice but without
further it just feels moot to talk about
anything other than arrows well like
good news is our first story is more
Eris talk we also have you heard about
this book conspiracy theory no I'll tell
you about it without further I did it
did it do here are the past five stories
that you need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by liquid IV
liquid IV is the category winning
hydration brand fueling your well-being
and their hydration multiplier is the
one product you're missing in your daily
routine now let me tell you how the
Airbnb this weekend was stocked with
liquid IV and it kept the group alive
people were like throwing them in their
purses it was like it's kind of like a
currency like I'll give you a liquid IV
for a pack of cigarettes like literally
I'm just kidding not cigarettes but you
know what I mean so one stick of liquid
IV in 16 ounces of water hydrates you
two times faster and more efficiently
than water alone so on a weekend like
this weekend hydration is key we were
drinking we were sweating we were
outside staying on top of your hydration
and making the most of your water
consumption with a liquid IV stick is
the thing to do they come in 12
delicious refreshing flavors to keep
your hydration routine exciting I love a
strawberry delicious they contain five
essential vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12 and
vitamin C so if you're exerting a lot of
effort or if you're you know going to
dehydrate yourself from drinking staying
on top and making sure you drink liquid
IV is the smart thing to do that's why
I'm here today it's made with premium
ingredients it has three times the
electrolytes of a traditional sports
drink and it's non GMO and free from
gluten dairy and soy grab your liquid IV
Nationwide in bulk at Costco or you can
get 20 off when you go to liquid iv.com
and use code toast at checkout that's 20
off anything you order when you shop
better hydration today using promo code
toast at liquid iv.com liquid IV in my
opinion is The Unofficial sponsor of the
era's tour because like you're going to
be dancing you're going to be shaking it
off you're going to be sweating you
might be cocktailing like you need a
liquid IV in your purse put it in your
clear bag and take it before the concert
after the concert you will thank me
today's episode is also brought to you
by Kitsch they say that hair care is the
new skincare but there's one brand that
is taken it to the next level with a
cult like following kitch has created
game changing Essentials Beauty
enthusiasts swear by from satin
pillowcases to time saving towels
kitchener's hair care doesn't stop at
the shower so whatever your budget
whatever your skin type and whatever
your hair type kids believes that you
deserve little indulgences at affordable
prices morning noon and night so their
hair care products are some of my
favorite I've recently switched to a
satin pillowcase and a satin eye mask
from Kitsch and I no longer wake up with
like a rats nest you should have seen me
in Nashville my hair was so crazy
because I didn't have my kids products
and I had to redo my hair every morning
which just like causes more heat damage
takes more time and it's just like an
annoying effort but sleeping on a satin
pillowcase is such a fabulous thing and
the ones from Kitsch are really
affordable and really good they also
have heatless satin curling rollers so
you can say goodbye to heat damage they
are the original OG heatless curlers
don't settle for the knockoffs get the
ones that started the craze everyone on
Tick Tock is obsessed they also have
rice water shampoo bars that could help
with overall hair growth and density and
rosemary scalp oil that will help
support scalp health and hair strength
from root to tip so if you're suffering
from like thinning or hair loss that
Rosemary scalp oils really good and
proven to work and rice water which is
like a hack to get your hair to grow
they come in shampoo bars now so right
now kitchen's offering you 30 off your
entire order at mykitch.com toast that's
right 30 off anything and everything at
my Kitsch
m-y-k-i-t-s-c-h.com slash toast that's
my kitch.com toast for 30 off your order
thank you turdy Lou you're welcome our
first Story Taylor Swift and rumored
Beau Maddie Healy are pictured for the
first time together as they head to her
condo following her era show
they were spotted in the car very blurry
picks but I'm it is him and it is him he
went to all three nights of the Eris
tour and it's kind of the Nashville
confirmation that I said we were gonna
get no I'm shocked like I like I don't
know what this could mean if not that
they're dating and you know Taylor has
been single actually recently heard from
like a good source since December so
she's ready to go so some people are
like this is fast it's really not like
she's been single since December he's so
supportive like he was on like the other
side of the world doing he's on like
doing shows and stuff like he's a busy
successful person so he came for all
three nights in Nashville Nashville is
like a special place to Taylor it's
where she got her star you know Bluebird
Cafe Etc et cetera
um so it's giving supportive boyfriend
it's giving boyfriend right it's giving
boyfriend and the other piece of news
was that they appeared to mouth secret
messages to each other at their concerts
so he did a show May 3rd in the
Philippines and it looks like he says
this is about you you know who you are I
love you while on stage she just moused
it between songs
artists are like weird yeah yeah he
could be talking saying anything to
anyone but then Taylor the first night
in her Nashville show did the same the
same thing and now the same thing so
maybe this is about you maybe it's I'm
trying to just think like if they're not
dating what it could be maybe they're
coming out with a song and this is like
a lyric on it that's like not a bad call
no I feel like
it's no but the song was for midnight so
if she wrote it like a long time ago was
it really about him or maybe it's like
here's a song that I wrote a while ago
but sums up how I feel about you
I don't know which song was it again I
don't know oh I didn't even think to
like look into what song it was she's
wearing her white dress it's it wasn't
midnight no it was like a folklore it
was folklore it was Folk because she was
wearing that white ethereal dress yeah
yeah yeah
what was the [__] song I don't
even think it matters like but this is
about you
oh yeah
so I want to know what she would say to
him I I'm so confused like I just want
to say like I'm so here for it this is
just exciting like I'm I really didn't
think we would get like so soon or
really ever like Taylor's single era
like with other celebs like she's I feel
like she's just loving like she's the
most famous she's ever been she's the
most universally Beloved the most
well-respected especially after last
night her show like coming off the heels
of like Morgan Wallen canceling his
stadium tour like because his voice hurt
but like you know he canceled a week
right cancel three shows but like the
night of that one but sorry you just
made it seem like the whole tour was off
no sorry it's like coming off the heels
of that like
last night Taylor it was pouring rain it
was lightning so like most people just
would have canceled Taylor waited like a
couple hours for it all to pass
brought everyone back into the stadium
after they like sheltered in place and
proceeded to do a show till two in the
morning in the pouring rain she would
have to pay like a big fine I think like
100 Grand because she went past curfew
The Sound Ordinance or whatever like so
professional like do anything for her
fans like she's in this place she's
never been more successful more loved
more popular and like
we're just eating it up and now like
there's like an element of like dating
to it how exciting is that yeah
and she's in control of all of it like I
feel like she's been really popular in
her career but never had like this level
of just like total control that's such a
good point you know yeah it's like
everything we're seeing like she wants
us to see you know yeah yeah she could
have gotten back into her speaker and
went home to her condo right and we
would never have seen her with Matt
right Maddie Maddie yeah call him Matt
just because I don't know him like that
yeah no it feels weird to call someone a
nickname and you don't like really know
them yeah like Maddie that's like very
cozy yeah intimate I know that's what
his fans call him but I can't say I'm
one of them yet that's fine that's fine
I haven't listened to Chocolate I've
only heard chocolate Claudius
[Music]
you're only a fair a fan of the 1975
Claudia's version yeah wait this book
thing
okay so you know like when books are on
like the Slate to be published like they
haven't been announced yet all the
bookstores and the Publishers they get
titles that's how people's books get
leaked like it's not that that's the
process right it's not like high
security yeah there is like a somebody
noticed like
there's like a a book coming out
that they won't release the name or the
title or the author for and it comes out
I think July 9th that July 9th the beat
of your heart it jumps through your
skirt and then this weekend when Taylor
announced speak now Taylor's version her
message on Instagram said dear reader
which everyone could think is like a
heart back to her song Dear reader from
Midnight
um but now it's just making us all think
so you think there's a Taylor's writing
a memoir that's coming out July 9. a lot
of people do the book is on Amazon with
no title no nothing and it's like the
number what people are pre-ordering it
it's the number one book and it might
just be this like unknown artist who's
like I mean unknown author someone who
like didn't get their things in on time
who has the number one book on Amazon
and they don't even know it but people
are really convinced it's Taylor's book
I mean
if if Taylor's book we're choosing it
for the redheads and I'm coming on okay
well I don't know if she would do a book
in the middle of
middle you know I don't know yeah it's
after speak now comes out right it's
like it's like a little much
it's just a little random
I don't know this could be like you
crazy ass Swift yeah it could be it
could be but it also could just be so
obvious but there's literally nothing
obvious about it except for the fact
that there's a book on Amazon
and she said dear reader
July 9th too because you know she does
important dates well she has a lot of
dates in Her Arsenal so yes July 9th
though is one of them how but like that
could just be a coincidence if she has
10 dates that are like tailor dates
that's one of them the 13th of any month
so 12. 13th of every month April 29th
July 9th December 13th maybe even the
31st of every month why no no no no no
no no no no no no but she does like
everything you know maybe Camacho
October 3rd
why ten and three yeah but then you'd
have to include 23.
8 10 23.
so it wouldn't you include the year yeah
so like it would actually be like
something that needs to equal eight like
five three twenty three June 3rd or
January March May 3rd that's when you
saw her now no that's
the sixth now I hear what you're saying
but July 9th is not anything to just
scoff at like it is something but it's
everything is something
I mean a book would be so good so good
she's such a prolific writer I just like
I don't want to get excited I don't like
to go down these rabbit holes I know
guys I know no I I actually have been
like taking a step back from the rabbit
holes like I find them extremely toxic
but this one like I kind of slipped into
and it's like I kind of feel it
I just think it's too random of timing
in the middle of the tour two days after
the timing is TV
oh and we forgot to talk about the cheat
on speak now TV we should like shot your
pants if she announced it at your show
yeah it's probably for the best honestly
like because I honestly I did have
Diaries your new skirt totally it was a
pricey skirt too like I can't be
[__] in it yeah you know that
wouldn't be cool the art is God
yes all the new artwork for like her
albums that she's like obviously just
recreating them but like in a more
mature and like slightly different and
somebody pointed out like you know she's
pretty much turned in every you know of
her original and she's turning the other
way it's like turning a new Leaf like in
speak now she's you know turned over her
left but in speak now Taylor's version
she's turned to her right and that means
that there's a book coming out on July
9th precisely because she's turning the
page
you said it not me
so that is all the Taylor news from the
weekend I believe I believe
who knows
this [__] is doing the most like I know
I think so you think she's so tired but
it's like was this just like a really
big week like would this weekend it felt
so significant if you guys weren't there
yes but like would it have been the top
yeah her and Matt Healy in the car yeah
yeah yeah you know it would have been a
story but like we wouldn't have had
boots on the ground information no we
would not have the OTG we would not have
botgi
so that's the official Hillary cap it
seems like things are going great with
Taylor
I think it's a great time to be a Swifty
and to be Taylor Swift yeah where does
she head next for the tour that's a good
question I don't know are you gonna go
again at MetLife yes of course
nice yeah
are you ready for our next story yeah
the other big news of the weekend King
Charles Carr Nations he has officially
been crowned in Westminster Abbey God
Save the King so there was a lot to
unpack there's a lot to unpack so many
cast members in showed up situation that
we could just and we do analyze every
single second down to Prince Louie's
yawn and I just I feel like it makes me
annoyed for him because I feel like he
actually was on good behavior for him
but he yawned once and like that's the
picture that goes viral the thing is is
like leave the kids alone like first of
all how boring like remember we used to
have to like go to Temple or like if you
had to go to church as a kid like it was
so boring like no one was looking at you
like at the Jubilee like he was doing
the most and it was really funny and
stuff and they like they wanted to make
that moment again but like it was just a
yawn like little kid live he did behave
really well like I saw him on the
balcony waving like he was doing a good
job I read they had a nanny ready to
snatch him of course the natural was
that the Carnation I saw lots of clips
from Katy Perry's perform it looked she
really is like such an underrated
performer she's kind of like in her
retirement era she doesn't really do
music she doesn't perform that much
she's like American Idol but we forget
we forget and she gave uh a big she did
a roar in this big gown she has amazing
vocals like you know what she was a
great selection did you also see Ed
Sheeran people were like he spoke he was
been doing a lot of press and somebody
asked him about the Carnation like why
he said no he's like I saw this a
million articles saying I said no I was
never asked
yeah excuse me yeah I just don't I don't
know how that's possible and that makes
me think that like all the other people
who were like alleged to have said no
weren't asked either not all of them no
but that makes no [__] sense I'm
sorry like yeah I mean it that's I just
don't believe that's the whole truth I
don't think Ed's lying but like I just
feel like
that makes no sense they definitely ask
like well he said they didn't maybe
Charles is like not a fan yeah maybe he
prefers more like American pop
princesses
can you blame him no you can't so other
news from I haven't watched really the
Carnation concert I want to watch Katy
Perry Lionel Richie and they also have
like other smaller artists I saw there
was like a Romeo and Juliet really sweet
um and it looks really nice also King
Charles Cavalier Spaniel and queen
Camilla like came on American Idol did
you see that video what Lionel and Katie
shot from Windsor Palace a little
message for American Idol and the two of
them crashed it's cute they're not
crashing anything they literally
stumbling yeah yeah but it's really cute
that is cute like weird to like put such
a fixation on like American Idols it's
like a fully British thing but like
whatever
um I think he wants to just include
everyone let's talk about the picture
you know how I always talk about you
know that picture of Megan and Harry
with the umbrella in the rain and the
blue dress how that's like a textbook
historic photo we got one
of Kate Kate looking out the window with
the rain and the jewels in her hair and
the Glam she obviously she got like
Patrick Todd to do her makeup she'll
[__] snatch she never really wears a
lot of makeup like she did like full
Kardashian Glam she looked amazing she
looked amazing also her outfit and her
crown and everything was not what I
expected at all and the fact that she
matched with Charlotte it was really
like modern but also not it was I feel
like Game of Thrones like the cape it
was sickening and it's not the choice I
would have thought that she would make
or even that I would make I would go
like you know Carnation happen in like
80 years I would be as traditional as
one could get with like an actual Tiara
but no she
killed it no she stole the show like
Beyond I think everyone was like Harry
no Kate stole the show but Harry was
there and everyone is really fixating on
the fact that he got shafted seat wise
one because he wasn't sitting with like
you know the core members and two
because he sat behind Princess Anne who
wore the biggest hat you could not see
Harry at all I'm sure he honestly didn't
mind in terms of like you know it's so
awkward so we didn't have to make eye
contact with anyone but like it is like
kind of like a slap in the face
yeah yeah he also fled London like an
hour after he did not stay for tea no he
didn't no biscuits he wasn't on the
balcony I don't think he would have been
invited to be on the balcony but I think
that that makes sense because they're
very much like about the nuclear family
um
like the thing is like him not that's
always been Charles's thing is trimming
the family down yeah but like if he was
on it we would be like yeah he's nuclear
family and he's not on it but like he's
not he's really both like if they had
another brother it would be interesting
we would always be comparing yes we
would always be comparing how the two
brothers are being treated but it's just
the two of them and one of them is the
successor it's like we could argue both
sides you know till we're sick yeah but
I don't think it's like a huge deal that
he wasn't on them he doesn't live in
he's also like exited the royal family
he wrote a [__] book like you're not
going on the balcony bro I know like the
fact that nobody here wants you on the
balcony it's a small space the fact that
like he was still there given like the
book the Oprah the documentary like it's
so weird it's so weird it's so
unself-aware and I saw just pictures of
him at like at the ceremony and like
walking in and stuff and he was like
smiling so big and it just felt like so
fraudulent like so fraudulent obviously
you're not happy to be there you hate
them they hate you and like your wife
hates them your family he's not there
like this is a very contentious
situation like you haven't seen them
since you wrote a whole last book about
them one of three about everyone in the
room yeah and you're saying that
institution like you think we don't know
why yeah it's it's honestly bizarre that
he went
yeah like I don't I don't really get it
I I think he like wants to have his cake
and he really wants to it's like you
know family family and I'm so family
family of course but it's like I think
after the book like we draw the line in
the documentary yeah honestly after
Oprah after Oprah yeah but there were
still things like they went to the
Jubilee yeah it was also Archie's
birthday her funeral
her his funeral Philip right
it's just weird
yeah yeah look of course Megan didn't go
like so why did he
because he like I don't know he he like
needs some sort of he like
like he has this a need I feel like of
like validation from like the British
people I think he thinks like the
British people love him but the ones
that go and like stand outside of the
Carnation like they don't love him no
no
I don't know I just have to make a
choice you know I'm just also like so
Random I'm not like seeing Camilla as
Queen like I don't know why she doesn't
give Queenie energy no but also that's
because well one like the previous Queen
was like the queen and now she's she's
the queen
via marriage which is just like a
different role role and that's why we're
like more focused on King Charles no for
sure it's just like they say king and
queen I'm like no it's the king in
Camilla like I'm all in on the royal
family I just like wish
there was more to root for with King
Charles you know he's like such a loser
like for real especially like the crown
did him Nary a favor like he like if you
thought he was a loser before the ground
like he was in a bigger loser after the
crown and I don't know he's just like if
it was his name weren't King Charles I
probably would like him less if his name
weren't King Charles I would my
enthusiasm level would be halved agreed
I'm obsessed with and by the way him and
Camilla should get a King Charles for it
oh if they don't for the palace missed
opportunity like
doesn't like you know traveling abroad
neither did strikes but he would do it
for the monarchy right and for the breed
and for the breed and there hasn't been
to King Charles in the palace for a
while no because the Queenie was kind of
anti-charged she was Corgi she was a
corgi girly and the doctor that was like
her one fault that she didn't love King
Charles cavaliers because they're so
Royal and she was such a dog person
she was obviously just like advised by
you know dumb ugly people Miss yeah it
wasn't her it was the people around her
agreed and then she falls in love with
corgis and then that's her like you know
what I mean it's kind of like us she's
like a victim of circumstance I think
also the whales is she get a King
Charles
yeah they need a dog I think they have a
dog like a big dog yeah it's like very
American of them yeah but they need a
King Charles yeah someone needs a
[__] King Charles it was
honestly a great weekend for you know
the king to be and the queen to be like
I feel like they stole the show like I
literally forget that the day was about
Charles all the pictures I saw were of
Kate and the kids and William and he
looked so handsome and Regal and she was
just giving glamor Elegance
sophistication snatched her Contour like
she was wearing like a smokey eye it was
really about them even though it wasn't
yeah and I think as much as like Charles
wants to be like the number one guy in
this group I think he also wants the the
royal family to remain really popular
and so all of that will and Fanfare and
popularity for the whales is is good for
the whole ship yeah but like it's just
so sad like honestly what a miserable
like life it's never been about Charles
like even when the day is supposed to be
about him we're all like look at kids
eyeliner look at Kate's dress like he's
just like he's not a main character yeah
energy his Birthright is to be the main
character but he was always Elizabeth's
son and now he's William's dad like we
don't care
and like no amount of jewels like
Camilla wearing this big ass necklace
like we still don't care
sad at least he has Camilla it's true
like the one thing he wanted in life
that he fought so hard for he got and
you know what they really are so in love
it's actually sweet yeah it's like the
notebook yeah if you change your
perspective if you change your
perspective like Diana was James Marsden
we love James Marsden love
yeah but we all took Ryan Gosling's side
and Ryan Gosling is Camilla whether you
wanna
we hate her or love her like it is the
truth yeah it's a love story in its own
weird way it's a modern [__] up love
story yeah
so happy for the Royals I didn't get to
consume as much of the content as I
wanted to I'm not really sure the time
difference by the time we woke up it was
over and then I kept feeling like I was
already missed the Carnation concert but
I didn't did you see Lionel Richie at
the car Nation he looked unreal I only
saw Katy Perry but like it's on my list
of things to do to go watch like he went
to they went to the ceremony too Katie
do you see Katy Perry at the ceremony I
did she looked hilarious like she but
her outfit was fabulous like it wasn't
so like shiny like she just Blended in
but the footage of her looking for her
seat she was like alone I feel like
these celebrities are used to going to
events with like publicist agents
assistance managers but like there's no
this is a carnation like you walk in by
yourself and you look at your ticket and
you go find your seat and she'd be like
wandering around with her fascinator on
like not able to find her seat and it
was truly honestly she never looked so
cute like it was hilarious really cute
it was funny I didn't see anything of
Lionel Richie but like I love that they
had each other they're obviously like
friends they work together and honestly
like it's a cute friendship it is I'm
gonna watch the I'm sure the concert's
on YouTube now I wonder if the granges
were there they're like so yes they went
to the Carnation concert I don't know if
they went to Carnation Day because I
don't think Sophia posted a picture of
herself like and I meant the parents oh
because they're like Aristocrats he's a
lord lord and she's a lady yeah so
they're Aristocrats and Lionel the
familial connection
did Sophia what did she post she posted
once she posted Lionel's outfit of the
Carnation ceremony and then she posted
like her outfit going to the concert oh
how excited so I'm sure the parents were
there too yeah the parents were
definitely there like probably like I
had seats yeah in the church yeah
very exciting
very exciting happy for the new king and
queen me too it was a nice weekend for
everyone yeah Americans in Brits alike
American Royals British Royals yes
are you ready for our next story what
story number is this three oh damn okay
it's It's upsetting news that
Yellowstone will end with season five in
November and a sequel series will debut
a month later okay so it's they're
giving us the good with the bad I want
to take responsibility
um I feel like one like once I started
watching the show like everything went
downhill like it was all going fine and
well and seamless until I you know turdy
Lou showed up and two obviously Taylor
Sheridan was like really rattled by you
know my my aggressive appearance
Behavior at Stagecoach and he was like
you know what I don't think I can do
this anymore so I take responsibility
thank you charity I will not fault you
because I know how that feels because
when I love something at least I got
five seasons of a show that I love Yeah
would you love something usually I get
one it's like the kiss of death like
yeah oh Jackie likes the show better go
cancel it yeah it's not meant for the
world to see yeah it's the end of an
hour for Yellowstone in the beginning of
a new one the modern day Western will
conclude following its next installment
which will Air in November on Paramount
Network pending the length of the
current writer strike though oh right
but the show will also go on as the
studio has ordered yet another sequel in
the Taylor Sheridan created franchise
one with Yellowstone in its title to
debut in December no casting has been
announced for the new series although
it's been rumored that the network was
in conversation with Matthew McConaughey
oh yeah for the dutton-centric spin-off
and it's feeling like that's what it's
gonna be okay but like what does that
mean for all the characters we know and
love rip and Beth like
yeah they're done too I don't think I
don't think necessarily I'm sure they're
still working it all out but this show
the Dutton story continues picking up
where Yellowstone leaves off in another
epic tale so
there is room for the characters we know
and love to be in it but there's also
room for Yellowstone to continue without
Kevin Costner like I just want to say he
might have been the initial draw to the
show he was his big name it was on a
network nobody had heard of
but like the show I did such a good job
of making you fall in love with so many
of the characters like it could be
conceived he dies
and we could move on and it's like the
Legacy what do we do now and it's like
Beth rip and Casey like there's there is
like it just feels like a little
premature I would say yes but did you
watch last night's succession no
I'm oh two episodes behind
positively Dreadful no my by the way
once okay so you planted a seed in my
brain that succession stings and now I
watch it I'm like this is a worship on
television I then planted the seed in
Abe's head Abe called me last 96 you
watched succession the show was horrible
I'm telling you once we are opening
people's eyes last night's episode like
now I'm officially done I like I would I
was watching to recap it on the show and
stuff and also sometimes I don't have a
lot going on on a Sunday night not a lot
going on at the moment yeah um but you
know what I started the show working
moms I wish I watched that last night oh
my God Wade do you never watch that show
no I started from the beginning yeah
it's so good it's a really cute Zach and
I are really enjoying it and I'm glad
that I waited till I was a mom to watch
it because I feel like I wouldn't have
enjoyed it as much because there's like
a lot of really Niche mom stuff mom
stuff that I'm like yes and by the way
you the final season just was released
on Netflix you have so much content
ahead of you I think it's like six
seasons yeah so like I wish that I
watched that last night or watch the
patreon Vlogs and said I watched it this
morning like
succession was positively Dreadful so
sorry it's not even about and I blame
you for looping me back in because I was
done after Logan died but then you made
that next episode sound so good with the
letter and the crossout
okay not like you blaming me for HBO's
problems no it's a compliment that you
make every like you just made it I am a
great Storyteller yeah and I feel like
that Drew me back in last I I and I
forgot what happened last week but it
was just it's bad like me and Zach are
both sitting on our phones yeah and I'm
like is this over yet I want to go to
sleep no it's so like Dreadful and it's
like colorless and lifeless and it's
just boring it's not funny like Logan
was the only comic I agree nobody else
is funny and it's really really bad so
what does that mean for Yellowstone
because once like the person does that's
what I'm saying like you would think
okay succession now we'll have the the
act of succession and who's gonna take
over but it's terrible the only
difference being that like we love rip
and Casey and Beth and like there are
lovable characters for me on succession
like I really only loved Logan no but
and on succession like the writing is
like meant to like nothing's ever really
supposed to happen like that's the whole
concept
like not the storyline never moves
forward it's like oh they crowned a
successor temporarily like that's the
whole point they're like [__] with us
Yellowstone they don't do that the
writing the writers don't [__] with us
yeah I guess that's become the point of
succession yeah people say that it's
satire yeah
um I don't get it no but like then
wouldn't we be laughing
I'm not saying that like in a shady way
but when I watched when I think of
cessection like I don't think of a
comedy yeah it's a drama I don't I
honestly don't know what the [__] it is
and I'm so like I have no desire I
actually had my on my computer that the
new episode downloaded on my flight home
from La six hours my flight to Nashville
and my flight home from Nashville and I
didn't even open like I'm so
uninterested Claudia it's so bad but
look for the culture all for the toast
like I will watch yeah you really don't
I don't think that you need to protect
your piece I'm devastated about
Yellowstone I'm not gonna lie like this
is really tough me too and just to know
that like it's not all hunky-dory behind
the scenes and it doesn't feel like the
family that we think that is no like
everything we've been hearing about like
Kevin and like now the divorce like it's
all you know there was smoke and there
is a fire
so at least they're giving us another
show yeah you know I mean Taylor
Sheridan is making way too much money to
just stop like yeah but he's got a lot
on his plate now he has 1923 4-6 is
coming up 1884. I'm excited about four
sixes Tulsa King he does too the
commercials that are so [__] loud do
you ever watch the commercials I watch
on Paramount Plus
oh and uh or no sorry on Amazon Prime
damn they've got to adjust the volume
I'm sorry it's messed up um before we
continue let me just let you guys know
that today's episode is brought to you
by go macro in the face of adversity and
a fight for survival against cancer a
mother and daughter took their love to
the kitchen and go macro was born now
they're spreading the power of a
balanced plant-based lifestyle across
the country with go macro available in
17 full-size mouth-watering flavors and
five kids flavors all go macro products
are certified organic vegan gluten-free
kosher non-GMO clean and soy free macro
bars are made from a combination of
plant-based ingredients that serve as a
healthy and delicious way to keep you
fueled throughout the day if you have a
food allergy or a dietary restriction
they offer three delicious nut-free
flavors including oatmeal chocolate chip
maple sea salt and sunflower butter plus
chocolate and 11 certified foodmap
friendly flavors so that everyone can
enjoy a delicious snack so if you are
constantly just like needing energy
needing a snack in your purse go macro
we have them at the studio Jackie eats
one probably everyone morning before the
toast and the way she chews them like
does make me want to strangle her but
she's a pregnant woman and I'm not going
to do that
um they're perfect to just throw in your
purse take with you on a long travel day
take with you at your desk they're
delicious get your hands on the
delicious
um new flavors that they have which is
mint chocolate chip they combine 11
grams of plant-based protein and organic
cashew butter with a touch of peppermint
and you can join us in supporting Farm
Sanctuary by going to gomacro.com and
using promo code toast for 30 off plus
free shipping on all orders of fifty
dollars or more again that's code toast
at go macro.com for 30 off plus free
shipping today's episode is also brought
to you by honey
the easy way to save When shopping on
your iPhone or computer thanks to Honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds to your cart here's how it
works when you're shopping online at one
of your one of your favorite websites
when you check out the honey button will
appear and all you have to do is Click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons I can find
for that site and if they find a working
coupon you'll watch the prices drop just
happened to me for the snatcher's
birthday gift I got a nice chunk of
change back thanks to honey last night I
bought something online and I got and I
was like uh oh no I don't need honey
maybe they could do something yeah like
oh my God I got like 25 off the amount
of things I've spent saved money on a
honey like makeup clothes Electronics
food gifts for the Satchel so many
different things they really cover such
a wide range of products and websites
and now you can also do it on your
iPhone they don't just work on desktops
anymore you activate it on your Safari
on your phone and you will save on the
go if you don't already have honey you
are straight up missing out by getting
it you're doing yourself a solid and
supporting the toast so get PayPal honey
for free when you go to joinhoney.com
toast that's
j-o-i-n-h-o-n-e-y.com slash toast to get
PayPal honey for free save yourself
money save yourself service save
yourself energy and joinhoney.com toast
thank you you're welcome our next story
Shawn Mendes and Camila Cabello are
getting cozy on an LA date night after
Coachella kiss yeah Sean and Camilla
were spotted getting cozy on a date
night in L.A the X's were spotted
hugging as they greeted each other for a
comedy show at the Hollywood improv on
Melrose they were also seen chatting
giggling and smiling each at each other
outside the venue they then headed to
the sunset Tower in West Hollywood like
there's hugging they're totally back
together and when those pictures
surfaced at Coachella Like the quote
that was given to page six by like
insiders close to Camilla were like no
like they're not dating it's just like
you know running into an ax like they
were gaslighting I was like they're
dating who cares or maybe like they
weren't they got back together at
Coachella like maybe they had a good Tim
I could tell you know emotions are high
there's your ex why not make out and
then and then they were like well why
not why did we break up in the first
place why did they break up in the first
place I don't know and actually
something I really like about Shawn
Mendes is like he's obviously this like
you know the hottest man alive like
everyone's obsessed with him and he
doesn't like thirst out and like date a
million people like he's really like
been in love with the same girl since
they met when they were 14 and like it's
actually really sweet I know a lot of
people are like this is boring like I
wish she would date like a million
models like I actually really like this
it makes me really like him that he's
not like thirsting and like going to
like a million clubs every night and
being spotted with different girls like
he met Camilla when they were both like
you know Vine and and X factories Vines
and trying times and like he just has
loved her since then like it's actually
really sweet it is really sweet I hope
they get married what do you think about
his outfit he's giving Coastal
grandmother oh not him wearing like the
origia pants that all the girls on Tick
Tock wear and like a sphinx bodysuit and
like loafers looks like it was something
Emma Chamberlain would wear totally
influence
it's not my favorite so to answer your
question it's not my favorite charm look
uh I'm happy for them like I hope that
this means that they're back together
true yeah I feel like it does and I
think that's nice I
feel like people are what does this mean
it's like they're on a date like they're
dating you know like that's what it
means yeah but I also feel like being
such so high profile if they wanted to
just hook up and not be back together
and keep it low-key like they wouldn't
be going to the Hollywood improv and
sunset Tower so yeah they're also
telling us something what are your
thoughts on like going to comedy shows
as dates like they know each other
really well so like it's fine but like
as like a date
because I always see Clips like Hannah
burner's always posting like she does
crowd work and like she's like calls out
like a people if you're on a date with
someone like it's not so awkward like
someone you don't really know oh not
because you're gonna be called out but I
think that like I would say not until
maybe after the fifth date is that an
option just like going to a movie
because we are here to get to know each
other that's true and you can't really
get to know each someone at a comedy
show but it is like a good bonding
experience like if you go to a comedy
show and then get dinner and you guys
can like be careful like do we have the
same sense of humor it's not something
that should be like in the really early
stages of dating because it's you know
you don't have that much time and it's
it's a long time
um you don't have to wait till your like
boyfriend girlfriend but I think like
first date second day what was your
first date
is that well the first time we like went
out was like with you and Ben but that
wasn't our first game then we just like
went to dinner the next night yeah me
and Ben did like drinks drinks is good
penny farthing penny farthing Third
Avenue and I think they sell Spritz now
full circle
full circle yeah like a like a few years
after that I made Ben go back to penny
farthing and like recreate the date and
like sit in the same table and I thought
it was like so cute and he like wanted
to kill me he's like this bar socks look
let's go I'm like no this is the
birthplace of our love and it sucks yeah
and it's like not it's like the most fun
bar it's just it's first it's for young
kids place in your life yeah it's like a
college bar yeah no but it was the spot
it is still the spot for for NYU kids
yeah I think yeah I think like a few
dates like maybe on our third date or
something Zach and I went to a concert
actually oh that's crazy which isn't
like a concert uh the weekend
yeah but I would say like that falls
into the same category as like a comedy
show but we had already been getting to
know each other for a while yeah you
guys had worked together you knew each
other like as friends plus like the cab
right there we talked right back all
right right right right because he was
at Barkley so it's a long ride oh that
is a long ride I would like feel
self-conscious to like dance like I
don't think I'm a very good dancer
you're a very good dancer and actually
so is Zach and we both love music so I
you know what it's actually the perfect
and you worked at iHeartRadio so you
were both like music people yeah and so
I guess like you and Ben actually could
have gone to a comedy show because we're
both like funny if you both have that in
common but you could go to a comedy show
with someone and like you could think
it's hysterical and they would be like
this is offensive yeah and then um but
then yeah it's best to know but also you
could see a bad comedy show and the
person's like that was so funny you know
it's best to know if they're like this
is offensive like they're obviously a
wiener and you shouldn't date them what
if you saw bad comedy and the person
thought it was funny
I think that's sweet I don't think
honestly I I do I think that's very
sweet
yeah
it depends and then I'm like oh your bar
for comedy is so low just wait till you
hear me yeah it depends on what kind of
bad comedy honestly yeah
right if it's like misogynist like like
no you know why because it's offensive
no I literally I found that I felt
myself I felt myself being hypocritical
it's a trap I trapped you no no by the
way I when I mean misogyny I mean like
hardcore like I have seen people sets
like doing jokes about like rape like
that's insane but then some other people
like make funny jokes about women like
and they're like this is massage no
that's not misogynistic it's just funny
yeah so I meant like actual misogyny
great thank you for the clarification
yeah no because I was being hypocritical
I felt no you're right like my bad my
bad
okay are you ready
final story wow already wow this is like
our longest show keep going yeah Amber
Heard quits Hollywood and moves to
Madrid okay wait I heard this but then I
also heard like reports are servicing
that she will be cast in the next
Aquaman so I had heard that and then
like a week later she's off in Madrid
well maybe she is moving to Madrid but
she's gonna like come do Aquaman you
know what this is giving
hmm
Evelyn Hugo and Celia they like moved to
Spain and like finally just like retire
but who's Celia I don't know just like
Spain oh he's like actors who are in
Spain I totally disagree okay cool
um I'll just go okay
[Laughter]
anyways Daily Mail claimed that they can
reveal that Amber has quit Hollywood and
quietly relocated to Spain with her
young daughter she's bilingual in
Spanish and is happy they're raising her
daughter away from all of the noise
they said I don't think she's in any
hurry to return to work or to Hollywood
but she'll probably come back when the
time is right for the right project so
next week for Aquaman 2.
um I just want to check something really
quick what are you gonna check
yes Amber Heard still follows me on
Instagram that's just like kind of one
of my claim to fans like something fun
and fresh about me yeah she's all
follows 52 people and turdy's one of
them so as someone who she follows what
do you think about this for her I mean
Spain is a gorgeous part of the world
like
she has a lot of money actually I don't
know
she's like payback and she's yeah and
now she's not working but I also think
like Elon and hell yeah because that's
elon's kid that's like a theory it's a
theory but but like no yeah but like
there were theories that he paid for her
lawyers too yeah that would have been
nice it's a very possible Theory but
it's been no way confirmed by either of
them so we can't say got it okay but
let's just assume
Elana helps with the bills
live your best life knowing Elon I got
some bills too so want to have a baby
he would love to he loves babies he does
he's kind of like the Nick Cannon of
tech yeah no together they're
repopulating the Earth you love that
yeah it's beautiful
um what was the story oh she's moving to
Madrid cool
yeah cool
it's awesome I hope she does Aquaman too
I've never seen any of the Aquaman I saw
Aquaman one and it was like not good wow
which is surprising because you love
Jason Momoa
Amber Heard Nicole Kidman not good
Nicole Kidman yeah I believe she plays
I don't know who is she in it Aqua mom I
like Aqua Mama yeah maybe and it was
just like stupid wow yeah for me like
I'll never be able to get past like the
Aquaman thing as it pertains to
entourage does anybody know what I'm
talking about yes I was just gonna
thinking that too and Nicole Kidman is
in it like I just don't know Patrick
Wilson who you love love Patrick Wilson
you should watch Aquaman nah that'll be
a good movie for you and Ben to watch
like if you're looking for common ground
it's like it's his birthday or something
I'll give him that yeah
um
laughs
what were you saying
Entourage oh yeah I'll never understand
how like Aquaman was like a fictional
movie like in a TV show and then like it
was real I don't get it because it was
it's really not that crazy Aquaman was a
cartoon that hadn't been made into a
movie yet it was a comic sorry not a
cartoon and so an entree she just made
it a storyline that like they're making
this comic into a movie which is and
then they just actually ended up doing
that yeah just
yeah but they do that all the time
that's like you know uh the Brie Larson
one who is she Miss Marvel or something
yeah marvelous Miss marvelous Miss
Marvel I love that yeah yeah I know I
understand what you're saying I just
like well I get it I still don't you
know yeah
to me like Aquaman is always just like
Entourage
until you see it by the way everyone was
singing this this weekend how can a
person know everything at 18 and nothing
about Dirty Lou what are the real lyrics
how can a person know everything at 18
and nothing at 22. well I like your
version better version also I think that
should be our title today when Jason
Momoa was cast in Aquaman like everyone
was like oh my god of course so we've
all like kind of gotten over against
this uh yeah
um which is kind of like one thing about
me like I am stuck in the past like I do
things like everyone says I should do
like I've actually been thinking like
maybe I'm gonna start working out like I
know people have only been telling me
that for 10 years but like this you're
finally ready it feels right it feels
like right much like a redhead's rating
that feels right
feels right reading yeah
I don't really meditate
okay I shouldn't I don't I don't I don't
need to really I don't meditate like
ever
okay I have a hatch and then just tell
me about the 13 on your hand oh I yes
it's written in Sharpie and I've taken
three showers and hasn't come off
um you shouldn't use Sharpie on your
skin no I'm aware it was just like not
even because it doesn't come off but it
gets into your bloodstream okay Grandma
like it's fine
um why couldn't you use something else
because I was gonna do it with makeup
cute and then I left my room and forgot
and then on the way out I just asked the
hotel desk if they had a Sharpie and
they happen to have like a glitter one
so it it is what it is who did the 13th
babe it's a nice 13. yeah I mean it's
fading but it was pretty good you should
have gotten a tattoo like from Amazon
once again great ideas after the concert
you're so helpful thanks for MetLife for
MetLife yeah thanks
that's our show that's our show the
Kurds are running out thank you guys so
much for listening to the test of Monday
Morning Show where we deliver Monday
Friday I need to be watching the YouTube
please don't subscribe
hope you guys have an amazing day we'll
see you tomorrow love you bye